Автомобілі Mercedes можна побачити на вулицях практично в усіх куточках світу.
Ці моделі зійшли з конвеєрів ще минулого століття. Але досі - на ходу.
Авто - зроблені на десятиліття.
Ця машина проїхала понад 1 мільйон кілометрів. Їй майже 30 років.
Ви знаєте, що дістанетеся до місця призначення без проблем.
Цей автомобіль наче каже вам: я можу тричі об'їхати навколо земної кулі
і при цьому залишитися найкращим. Це унікально.
Що ж робить автомобіль Mercedes таким витривалим?
Це скорочення до найнеобхіднішого вже тоді було революційним.
Конструктори Mercedes прагнули досягти максимально можливого рівня якості.
Секрет у простоті. Чим простіше - тим краще. Будьте простіше. Завжди можна все ще спростити.
Том Фішер - фахівець із реставрації старовинних автомобілів.
Щороку він ставить свою роботу на паузу, аби вирушити в експедицію до Африки.
У поїздку бере своїх вірних сталевих друзів - моделі Mercedes, які випустили в період з 1968 до 1997-го року.
Це було на кшталт хобі, моїм другим життям. Взимку я їздив сюди з Європи,
зі своєї майстерні, до Західної Африки, через Марокко чи Мавританію.
Навіть якщо їду через Сахару і на велику відстань, то знаю, що доїду до кінцевого пункту призначення.
Поціновувач класичних автомобілів знає все про ці оулдскульні Mercedes -
і він точно знає, що робить їх такими надійними та витривалими.
Це триває від самого початку існування бренду Mercedes, їхнього розуміння якості,
особливо у Штутгарті та його околицях.
Чому Штутгарт? Тому що саме там у 1886 році Карл Бенц випустив перший у світі автомобіль.
Навіть нині гості німецького міста Айнбек можуть здивуватися,
побачивши на дорогах Mercedes Benz, який був свідком зародження автомобільної ери і який досі на ходу.
Цей найстаріший автомобіль у Європі продовжує вражати також і сучасне покоління інженерів.
Ці деталі такі старі, але ще працюють! З технічної точки зору, авто не могло розвалитися,
бо концепція двигуна залишилася незмінною і до нині.
Двигун працював 117 років тому і продовжує працювати сьогодні. Приголомшливо.
Плюс технічне виконання є дуже точним. У той час вони не поспішали та не урізали вартість.
Весь цей досвід втілився у культовій моделі W 114: першому Mercedes, створеному для масового ринку.
Разом із наступною моделлю 115 - їх було продано близько 2 мільйонів екземплярів.
Наступним кроком в еволюції інженерної думки став W123.
У свою чергу, його замінив W 124, що випускався з 1984 по 1997 роки.
Як і його попередники, він вважається втіленням довговічності.
Це твердження можуть підтвердити таксисти, такі як Луан Ніна в Албанії, який проїхав на Мерседесі понад мільйон кілометрів.
На початку 80-х Пітер Пфайффер розробив наступне покоління, здавалося б, найвитривалішого автомобіля.
Як видно на прикладі W 124: пуризм, перфекціонізм був ключовим моментом.
W 124 спочатку був абсолютно так би мовити "чистим" -  зведеним до найнеобхіднішого.
Будьте простіше. Настільки простими, наскільки це можливо. Інженерія не обмежується жодними кілометрами.
Авто зроблені краще, ніж мали б бути. Або, могли б бути.
У той час інженери Mercedes вважали за честь працювати на найстарішого у світі виробника авто -
і прагнули створити найкращий автомобіль на планеті.
Маріо Тайссен із Міжнародної федерації історичних транспортних засобів оглянув безліч автомобілів.
Для нього німецька якість - заслуга німецьких інженерів.
50 років тому маркетинг не грав великої ролі у прийнятті рішень щодо виробництва продукції.
Тому саме інженери з науково-дослідної та виробничої частини визначали асортимент та планування продукції.
І насамперед вони звертали увагу на гарну якість проєктування.
Результат неперевершеної інженерної думки: Мерседеси, створені десятиліття тому в Штутгарті,
і досі працюють, працюють і працюють.
У деяких частинах Африки, наприклад, де люди не поспішають відправляти автомобілі на звалище,
термін служби Mercedes здається ледь не вічним.
Не тільки якість автомобіля дуже висока, але і метод ремонту
цих автомобілів досить простий, тому що більшість компонентів просто механічні.
Для берлінського дилера старовинних автомобілів Буркгарда Штайнса ремонт таких моделей, як Mercedes W 124 - саме задоволення.
Як бачите, моторний відсік не такий вже й заповнений.
Тут лише механіка. Ви можете працювати з простими інструментами для ремонту.
Іскри ви можете видалити за кілька хвилин.
У вас тут двигун без турбо, без будь-якого наддуву, компресорів чи ще чогось.
Оглянувши детальніше бачимо: шасі таке ж міцне, як і двигун.
У машині все габаритне, що стосується механіки.
Наприклад, тут є підшипники, ви бачите їх також і на передній осі.
Все дуже важке. Підшипники більші, ніж треба.
У цьому полягає концепція автомобіля: взяти найкращий матеріал, який тільки можна знайти.
І межа можливостей його використання закладена у конструкції цих автомобілів.
Досі модель 124 була вершиною майстерності в лінійці Mercedes щодо якості.
Після неї якість впала.
Наприкінці 1990-х років керівництво Mercedes-Benz ухвалило рішення про серйозні зміни.
Інженерні розробки були обмежені керівництвом.
Конкуренція ставала все більшою, і всі супутні бренди заробляли набагато більше грошей -
менеджери опинилися в ситуації, коли вони мали приносити більше грошей акціонерам.
І гонитва за прибутком в першу чергу позначилася на якості технологій виробництва.
Попередні постачальники були витіснені, аби можна було здешевити виробництво.
І якщо ви тиснете на постачальника, ви не отримаєте такої самої якості, як раніше.
І, звичайно ж, сучасні моделі оснащуються все більшою кількістю електроніки,
що не найкращим чином позначається на їхній надійності.
Сучасні автомобілі, які випускаються зараз, підуть у брухт через 15 або максимум 20 років.
Інша річ - ці машини. Ними можна їздити вічно.
Як це і роблять водії від Албанії до Африки та інших країн.
Вони, безумовно, цінують свої старі моделі Mercedes.
Автомобілі, створені для вічного використання і виготовлені у Штутгарті.